this is the 2023 cadillac lyric
not only is the lyric general motors
first all-electric cadillac the vehicle
represents the beginning of a major
strategic shift for the company
cadillac
needs to change from a manufacturer of
gas powered vehicles
to an automaker with an all-electric
fleet built on what gm is saying is a
revolutionary new battery system because
when it comes to this all-electric
future nobody nobody nobody nobody will
be left out and that changes everything
america's auto industry has long known
that the single biggest barrier to
widespread electric vehicle adoption is
battery cost
the theory goes that the companies that
can bring down their battery prices will
be able to create more affordable evs
and therefore stand a better chance of
being competitive in the race for
america's ev market
and general motors president mark royce
says his company is in a position to win
that race with its new battery system
you guys have been clear that you're
going to need a ton of battery capacity
i think the battery is is for now at the
core of of cost to vertically integrate
that and to actually develop our own
chemistry is a competitive advantage
and that's what's brought me here to
gm's test track in milford michigan
when it first opened in 1924 the milford
proving grounds was the industry's first
automobile testing facility
today i've come to this 4 000 acre track
to ride along in a test version of a
vehicle that gm says will play a pivotal
role in its future let's check this
thing out this lyric isn't quite ready
for the showroom what you're seeing is a
model still under development but with
the vehicle's launch date approaching
next spring royce offered to give me an
exclusive behind-the-scenes look so
let's talk about how important
the lyric is just in
for gm broadly this is the first fully
electric cadillac
almost 120 year history right that's a
big deal first is first this is the
first uh you know no kidding mainstream
uh you know transformation of cadillac
and the company it's it's all happening
with this car it's a reflection of
what's possible in january general
motors set 2035 as the target date for
when it hopes to complete its transition
to evs
currently 98 of gm sales are vehicles
that run on fossil fuels and the
company's best-selling cars are large
pickup trucks and sport utility vehicles
that are among its least fuel efficient
gm's brands chevrolet buick gmc and
cadillac have loyal followings but it
isn't clear if those buyers or new ones
will follow gm into its ev future
gm has also lagged behind in a market
where two competitors tesla and ford are
already doing well with new upscale suvs
it's more than cutting edge technology
it's the spirit of it it's a mustang
do you think this is a litmus test i
mean if this car turns out as good as
you think and expect that it will should
we see that kind of acceptance for a car
that doesn't have a tesla badge on it i
think so we made the investment across
the whole portfolio all the engineering
all of the component sets are cadillac
and i think people are going to see that
and they're going to see it as the tip
of the technology spear
gm has a long history of innovation in
the ev space dating back to 1912 when
the company built electric trucks with
lead acid and nickel iron batteries
in the mid-1990s gm developed the ev1
which was the first mass-produced
electric vehicle in the modern era from
a major automaker the car could only be
leased in a few cities and gm abandoned
the model after a few years
the modern race for ev dominance didn't
really begin until about 15 years ago
when tesla arrived on the scene with its
roadster i'm really excited by the fact
that we've got a zero emissions sports
car that can go head-to-head with a
ferrari and a porsche and win in 2010 gm
helped pioneer plug-in hybrid evs with
its compact chevy volt general motors is
getting back into the battery business
the volt was marketed as a practical and
affordable hybrid but was never a big
commercial success
gm didn't enter today's ev market until
2016 when it released the chevy bolt
this is truly an ev for everyone
for most people this can be their
everyday driver the bolt offered more
than 200 miles of range for the
relatively affordable price of 30 000
but sales have lagged behind tesla and
recently the bolt has become a costly
headache for gm this august the company
expanded a previous safety recall for a
fire risk related to lithium-ion
batteries supplied by korea's lg
the recall covers all of the 142 000
volts gm is built at an estimated cost
of 1.8 billion dollars
those are very serious things that
happen if you're putting the customer at
the center like we do of safety and if
we have a problem in this case in a
supplier who is making the sell for us
we bring the bear general motors
technical expertise to go in and solve
that and make it right for the customer
today the us ev market still makes up
only about three percent of all car
sales
in tesla which sold about two of every
three all-electric vehicles purchased in
2020 remains the sector's dominant
player
but other automakers commitment to evs
has intensified in the past year more
than a dozen new models are set to
arrive in u.s showrooms this year as
startups like rivian and established
automakers like ford and volkswagen show
the results of billions in technology
spending
just in the last
six nine months we've heard a lot of
announcements from some of your rivals
getting into the battery business
everyone's kind of sort of reading from
the same playbook now so
what's going to separate the winners
from losers i think until you get
dedicated platforms for eevee and not
derivative scarred architectures that
carry
you know the inefficiencies of an
internal combustion engine into an ev
platform is one of the key
differentiators
until recently many evs were built on
car platforms originally developed for
gas powered or hybrid vehicles
but because the mechanical layout of
electric cars is so different that has
meant that many evs have been
constrained in their design
gm which is america's largest automaker
by sales is betting big on its new
ultium battery system fewer wires within
the pack
allows room for more batteries helping
extend charging ranges
the technology uses a different
chemistry and design than the early gm
battery systems on the chevy bolt and
chevy volt
automakers are now transitioning to evs
with dedicated ev platforms like gm's
ultium system while expensive these
platforms offer more design flexibility
without some of the inefficiencies of
past evs with cars like the the lyric
here you know we're going to have over
300 miles of range we're going to have
you know the ability to charge you know
very quickly that's the kind of
flexibility that gives a competitive
advantage if you have the best chemistry
and you have it vertically integrated on
scale and that's what we're doing
today many electric car owners use their
evs as a secondary vehicle because
charging times limit use on longer trips
but royce is confident the lyric and
other future gm electrics will mark the
beginning of a sea change in how drivers
approach evs if you're offering things
that are ten thousand dollars more on a
vehicle that isn't as functional and
can't be a primary vehicle and you don't
know how to get that kind of charge time
on it that's kind of a no-go the whole
mission was you know to get to get
people to consider it as a primary
vehicle and then you see things really
start to change
[Music]
you